welcome everyone
this is Rob Sanders we simply learned
and today we are going to learn how to
create a YouTube channel so let's get
started with learning how to create a
YouTube channel I'm excited to be with
you and hopefully you'll get a lot out
of this webinar so the first thing you
need to do when you create a YouTube
channel is you have to have an email
address so one email address will work
with all Google products and since
YouTube is owned by Google the email
address you use to log in to Google
products for example Gmail will get you
into YouTube so I would recommend
setting up a new email address if you
don't want to use an older email address
so you just want to make sure the email
address you use is the one you're going
to use with YouTube and so it probably
will be easier just to go ahead and set
up a new gmail account and so you can
see here for today's webinar I'm gonna
use my email address robson or simply
learn a gmail so that's the email
address I'm going to use and once you're
logged in to Google so when you're
logged into one product technically
you're logged in to all Google products
if you're in the same browser so you can
see I'm in Firefox so if I went over to
Google and did a search I'm gonna be
logged in as Rob Sanders that's simply
them so generally that's how it works so
when you're logged into one you're
logged into all and so once you set up
that gmail address then you want to go
and log into YouTube with the same email
address so note that and all Google
products you can have multiple logins so
you can see here I can log in to
multiple accounts in the same browser so
here you can see I'm logged in as Rob
Sanders don't simply learn and that's
the email address I'm using to log into
YouTube so I'm logged into YouTube now
what do I want to do I want to create a
channel that's what this whole webinar
is about so we want to learn how to
create a YouTube channel and so the
first thing we're gonna do here is click
on our name and you can see that in the
upper right hand corner have an R for
Rob
click my channel since I've never
created a channel for this email address
now I have the opportunity to create one
so I'm just gonna use digital marketing
as my example here okay so by clicking
on this I agree to the Terms of Service
of YouTube so I'm gonna go ahead and
agree to those terms by clicking on the
call-to-action create channel and once I
click on create channel voila I have a
YouTube channel so now that I have a
channel I'm going to go ahead and
optimize my channel page so here you can
see I have a button that says customize
channel so I'm gonna go ahead and click
customize channel and this will get me
into customizing my channel so what's
the first thing I want to do well with
YouTube as a best practice you want to
be able to customize the channel as much
as you can and what do I mean by
customize a channel well you want to add
some channel art you also want to you go
ahead and put information about yourself
you want to go ahead and obviously
upload videos and create playlists so
we're gonna be covering throughout this
webinar some of these best practices and
if you haven't had a chance go ahead and
take a look at the videos we put
together regarding how to rank your
YouTube videos and also how to increase
create increase YouTube subscribers so
both of these videos actually complement
today's video and we do talk about some
of the best practices and setting up
your YouTube channel so these are good
videos to complement what we're doing on
YouTube so you definitely want to go
ahead and customize the channel so the
first thing we're gonna do is spruce up
our channel a bit and add some some
artwork and so I'm just gonna go ahead
and click on add channel art and I'm
gonna upload some photos here so I'm
gonna select a photo from my computer so
if I go to my desktop have it sitting in
a nice folder here ready to go and so
here I'm gonna go ahead and choose this
particular piece of art it's a PNG file
so I'm just going to go ahead and click
open so notice it says the photo you
uploaded is too small a must
at least 2048 pixels wide in 1158 pixels
tall so you got to make sure you have a
nice big photo that's going to fit this
particular requirement so because this
image was a little bit small what I went
ahead and did was adjusted the size so I
just opened up the file and adjust the
size so now if I look at my original
size and go to tools here
that's just size so i justed it so
basically it fits within the scope of
what YouTube is asking for in terms of
pixel dimensions so now I really applaud
it it and now I can see what it looks
like on TV on a desktop and on mobile
device so I can adjust a crop if I
wanted to if I wanted to I'm gonna go
ahead and leave it as is because we
don't want to crop anything out of it so
I'm gonna go ahead and select save and
there you go there's my image so a
little bit pixelated
but that's okay I can go in and upload
another image if I want to now once I've
uploaded my channel art I'm gonna go
ahead and upload my channel icon so I'm
gonna go ahead and click on edit and I'm
gonna go ahead and edit my channel icon
and so now I'm gonna go ahead and upload
a photo so you see I went ahead and put
all these images ahead of time in a
folder so that's what you want to do you
want to have everything prepared and
ready to go
just like your email address go ahead
and think about what particular images
you're going to use with your channel so
you want to have those ready to go and
so I'm gonna go ahead and pick my
channel icon and click open here's my
channel icon so I'm gonna click done and
it should upload my channel icon and
there you go so now I have a nice
channel icon which is the logo of my
company to go along with the artwork I
have for my channel so now i refresh my
channel page and here is my channel icon
ready to go along with my channel
artwork okay now that I have my artwork
in place I'm ready to upload a video so
just like the artwork just at the email
address you want to have that video
ready to go so to me you want to make
sure you're choosing a
good quality video because when you
upload that video you could make it
available to everybody on YouTube to
view so if this is your first video you
really want to make a good impression
and so by making a good impression is
make sure that first video is of good
quality now you can always upload a
video and remove it later for just
testing purposes that's fine
but if you're going upload a video and
keep it there make sure that video is a
good quality when I say good quality I
mean good video and audio quality you
know make sure you have a theme make
sure it fits what your channel is all
about because if somebody is looking on
YouTube and they're looking for
something related to what you're
offering that video needs to come across
as professional and you want to have a
good impression so that's my disclaimer
on uploading a video so now let's just
go ahead and upload a video so we're
gonna go ahead and we can go choose
videos or you can see here under uploads
says you don't have any recent uploads
so this will not appear in your channel
so we want to add a video so let's go
ahead and just click on the link upload
a video okay so now here's what I'm
referring to a minute ago you have the
option to make this public you can make
it private unlisted you could schedule
it let's just go ahead and make this
private for now okay so now let's go
ahead and select the file I have that
video ready to go so it's in my folder
here and so now I'm just gonna select my
video and click open and now it's going
to upload the video here I can see the
status of my upload of course videos
depending on your bandwidth may take a
few minutes may take a few seconds so
let's go ahead and wait for this to
finish processing and then we're going
to take the next step okay so once your
video has been uploaded it's gonna see
processing is done now you have the
opportunity to go ahead and fill in some
basic information so here you can see
you have three fields that you should
fill out with every video you upload you
have a title you have a description and
we have some tags here so the title is
the title of the video so this is
digital marketing certified associate
training DMCA training simply learned so
you how you you
basically customizing anything and have
it say anything you want it to say means
your video so you want to make the title
relevant to the video because that's
what people are going to see now I'm
gonna go ahead and put in some
information here about the video what is
the video about so here you can see I
prepared some content so you can add a
lot of characters here under the
description you'd see a lot of
characters and so you want to put as
much information about the video as
possible of course you don't have to add
all this content so we could just scale
it down you just want to have basic a
basic description and what the videos
about that's really what you want to do
and then you can add some tags so let's
go ahead and add some tags about the
video itself so this is a video about
digital marketing so we're gonna add
tags related to digital marketing so
here you can see we can add a hashtag
digital marketing we want to add another
one this one's about DMCA training so
let's go ahead and add that here now the
thing about hashtags you want to keep
the words all together and there's no
spaces involved okay so you can see I
just added two hashtags hint enter now
the thing is you don't want to overdo it
on the hashtags probably two or three
you know go excuse me YouTube will
probably ignore anything over a handful
of hashtags so you want to make sure you
don't overdo it on the hashtags like I
said one or two or three related to the
video should be all you need notice you
have a couple of other settings here
again we're just gonna keep this private
so only we can view this but if you're
ready to make this public then go ahead
and you know make it public just change
the setting from private to public now
if you have a playlist if you've already
set up a playlist you can add it to that
playlist if you don't well you can
create a playlist and here's a good
opportunity for you to set up a playlist
with your first video now if you're not
ready to set up a playlist and playlist
really are there to help you organize
videos so if you know you're gonna
upload more videos in the future then go
ahead and set these playlists to
organize your videos so we can go ahead
and create a playlist and we're
gonna call it DMCA so anything related
to DMCA we're gonna go ahead and put the
video there we're gonna make this
playlist public here you can see we can
keep it unlisted or private so we're
just gonna go ahead and create it and
just by checking on this box this video
will now be in the playlist DMCA so you
have the opportunity to really organize
your videos any way you want by creating
multiple playlists fact I would
recommend that and so again these are
the steps you need to take when you
upload a video you need to make sure
that the title tag the description and
the hash tags are all relevant to the
video in fact you want to make sure even
before you do that you align the right
keywords with the video so I want to
remind you we elaborate a lot on that on
the how to rank YouTube videos so go
ahead and take a look at this video here
how to rank YouTube videos and this will
get you going with ranking your video I
would recommend for now if you're not
sure how to do that and you're not ready
to watch the video how to rank YouTube
videos then just go ahead and make sure
you're lining the right title tag or
title description and hash tags with the
video and when you're done and you're
ready to go
you can click done and now you have a
video with a specific link so if I click
on that link I should be able to watch
the video I just uploaded so once we've
uploaded that video we do have the
option to go back and edit the video so
you can see I'm still in my channel I
clicked on videos if I just click on the
video itself I could see what the video
is and right underneath that there's
going to be a blue call-to-action button
that says edit video and so I'm gonna go
ahead and click edit video and so
remember we edited the video with title
tags the meta the description and some
hashtags but there are a lot of other
features that we can use or take
advantage of to edit the video so let's
take a look at what that is and what
that looks like so again we can go back
in and edit the title of the video we
can edit the description notice you have
5,000 character
so take advantage of all those
characters that YouTube is giving you so
we have the option to switch out the
visibility again change the playlist so
we're gonna have more tags so we have a
lot of different options at our disposal
okay so notice the thumbnail here so
YouTube selects three different
thumbnails so you can change the
thumbnail here and the thumbnail is what
the opening screen is gonna look like so
you can change that if you'd like okay
so if you make any changes just go ahead
and make sure you click Save you also
have some advanced features here so we
can add a recording date if you want to
basically put a timestamp on it we can
add a category in here for search so if
people are looking for specific category
this is where it'll be located so we're
gonna go ahead and change that we're
gonna put it under education okay we
have an option to select the language
okay so we're gonna go ahead and select
English okay we can have caption so you
have a lot of different options here to
really set up your video nicely to be
found to be published based on the
description all the other settings
available to you so when I'm done I'm
just gonna go ahead and click Save and
all my changes are saved and so again
those are gonna be located under video
so anytime I want to go ahead and edit
my video I'm just gonna go I can always
go back to my channel I can always just
click on videos on the left side
navigation and then from there again I
can just click on the video or I can
select it and then I can edit it and so
here you can see as an alternative I can
go to any one of these areas to edit so
if it'll come tags I can go ahead and
add it to tag so think of this as a
shortcut if you will if you want to add
it any one of these specific parameters
related to your video so let's talk
about some other settings you have
available to your channel so we went
through some of the settings for the
video itself
okay so again just as a reminder if you
need to edit the video you can just
click on or select the video that you
want to add it and you have some quick
edit options here so here Oh your edit
options you can quickly edit those or
again you can just click on the video
itself you can see you have some editing
options here as well okay so these are
settings related to the video and so if
I want to have edit some settings
related to the channel that's a little
bit different so if I go if I want to
change some of the settings on my
channel I can simply just on the left
side navigation where you got channel
you have dashboard videos analytics so
forth you can just scroll down and you
can see some settings here so you want
to click on that sprocket icon and then
you're gonna have your settings window
open up okay then I'm gonna click
channel okay so let's just say I want to
add a watermark to my channel so i'm
gonna click branding and as you can see
here adding any watermark to your
content it's just a really a great way
to really put your brand in place so
it's gonna add you know your brand to
every video that you do ok so it's gonna
overlay in the bottom right corner of
the video player and so that's what we
want to do we want to add a watermark
that's a best practice so go ahead and
choose an image again I have this
already prepared for me so I'm going to
go into my folder here and then I'm
gonna go ahead and select my image so
this is my logo I'm gonna go and select
that that image there and now I can see
here it added to the bottom right of the
video player and so it can be at the end
of the video at a specific custom start
time at the beginning of the video or it
can be throughout the entire video so
let's just go ahead and add it to the
entire video okay so I'm gonna go ahead
and click Save okay so now I've added a
watermark let's go back into settings so
there could be some other settings we
want to change so if I go back to
channel so here I can add some keywords
okay so this is key because if I want my
channel be found you know I want to be
able to tell YouTube what those keywords
I won't be found for just like in search
with Google YouTube and all intensive
purposes is a search engine it's just a
video platform where you can search for
videos and so my channel is all about
digital marketing so I'm gonna go ahead
and put digital marketing I can also go
ahead and put
you know search engine optimization I
can or SEO just to be shorter I can go
ahead and put SEM for search engine
marketing so these are just some
keywords here here I can choose my
country so I can choose my country and
choose like United States just a bone in
specifically on the country so let's see
here I'm gonna scroll down I'm gonna
choose United States is my country here
I get some advanced settings as well I
can link my Google Ads account to this
so this is key so if you if you're
running Google ads campaigns then you
want to be able to link it up so linking
your channel to your ads account
basically will you know allow you to get
some information about how this
particular channel is performing so
basically it lets the Google Ads account
run ads based on interactions with your
channels videos and access insights from
your channels videos so basically when
you link the two they're gonna be
communicating they're gonna be passing
data back and forth so if you have a
Google Ads account I would go ahead and
link it up okay so remember it's based
on email address so make sure the same
email address you're using for YouTube
is the same email address you're using
for Google Ads so I can go ahead and
choose this option to show my subscriber
count'
I can also disable intraspace that so if
I select this option personalized ads
will not be shown on videos on your
channel such as ads based on viewers
interest or remarketing so if you want
to go ahead and disable any interest
base that's and he adds again that are
based on a specific interest or
remarketing then you can disable that so
let's go back to branding here's my
watermark under branding again advanced
based on advertising and just some basic
options specifically keywords so go
ahead and make sure you go ahead and
choose settings and go ahead and add
those keywords go ahead and add that
watermark it's important to the channel
it's important you be found it's
important that you know your channel
setup the way you want it to be set up
with some certain keywords and a
specific industry target in a specific
country so you want to set that up
that's why so settings here are so
important for the channel okay so once
you created your channel once you've
uploaded a video once you set up all
your settings for the channel
congratulations
so you're really on your way now to
uploading more videos and really having
a successful YouTube channel so
congratulations now let's move on and
get a little bit more complex here with
the YouTube channel so we're gonna move
on to the next step and we're going to
run through the creator studio and the
beta studio okay so I'm gonna go ahead
and show you what the creator studio I
made of studio R so let's focus first on
the creator studio and so basically the
creator studio we have some tools to at
our disposal okay so we have a dashboard
where we could see certain analytics we
have a video manager we can actually
edit the video we have an opportunity in
a live stream work with our community
and we have some channel settings we can
play with the audio again we can you
know manipulate and look at some
analytics and react to the analytics so
you have a lot of options here in
creator studio so let's go into YouTube
and let's dive into the Creator studio
and take a look at what that's all about
so when we go to YouTube and our channel
basically what we see here is our
Creator studio if you will so we have a
lot of different options so we talked
about videos already and how to edit
videos we talked about settings well
let's talk about some of these other
options available to us in the Creator
studio so this is the dashboard so the
dashboard is going to give you an
overview of your channel so here we
could see a snapshot of some subscribers
some data over the last 28 days so if we
look here we can see some other
performance metrics based on analytics
okay so we can YouTube can give us some
ideas we have some news so it's a
dashboard that a YouTube is
communicating with you on so they're
communicating data about your videos
that
uploaded what's been popular you know
how many times somebody's viewed it how
many subscribers and then you also have
some communication information some tips
some suggestions some ideas so that's
what the dashboard is and if you're new
to YouTube I would definitely take
advantage of it you know for example
ideas for you grow your communities so
if we get started you know YouTube's
gonna be able to you know share some
information about you know how to create
or how to grow your community so you
know go ahead and take advantage of you
know some of these options that YouTube
has for you so you have ideas you have
some inscri tour insider and you have
some news so don't be afraid to go ahead
and click on and get some tips about you
know growing your community for example
so here you can see some courses and
some lessons that YouTube put together
and again at YouTube we have the same
simply learn we have the same
information for example we have a video
on how to increase YouTube subscribers
but you can look at our videos you can
also you know lean on YouTube for some
information as well and all that's
located here in the dashboard let's talk
about the video manager so basically we
click on videos so we'll be able to see
videos that we have here so you can see
in in this particular channel you can
see all the videos that we have here and
you can see the visibility of those
videos are they public yet or they
unlisted are they private we have a
stamp of when they've been uploaded the
date of which they've been uploaded and
then you can kind of get a sense of how
many views how many comments how many
likes vs. dislikes 5 video ok so we want
we can always just click on one of the
videos here and again we can edit it so
we have an opportunity to you know make
some edits and changes to the video
itself especially for not getting
comments we're not getting views if
we're not getting views then you
probably should go forward and think
about editing say the title or
description or or making sure you align
the right keywords or tags with the
video ok so that's the video manager we
go to analytics in our creator studio
then we'll be able to get some really
deep insights about
how our videos are performing so there's
a lot of information here under
analytics about you know all your entire
channel broken down by each video so if
you wanted to really hone in on what the
top videos were in terms of watch time
you can specifically choose that
particular report and then what's going
to happen is YouTube's going to load the
report and we're gonna be able to see
specific information about a specific
video okay so again this is overall but
if I want to see analytics for specific
video I'm gonna go down under the video
and click on this little graph here and
I'll be able to see some insights about
that specific video and so for that
specific video I can see the total watch
time how many views subscribers and I
can see audience retention I can see
real time activity
I can see watch time over a period of
time see subscribers over a period of
time so you can get really granular all
the way down to the video so a lot of
information in YouTube analytics about
your overall channel and the video
itself so it's all here for you to
measure and look at so remember when
you're looking at this analytics you
want to go ahead and react to what you
see so again if you're not getting
subscribers or you're not getting views
what are you gonna do well if you're not
getting views you gotta look at this the
settings you're gonna look at the
keywords you got to look at did you
actually update and edit the title and
the description and add a hashtags that
are relevant okay so if they are
relevant you know are you getting found
okay so that's the whole idea is to make
sure you're optimizing these videos so
you can get the views and again is the
quality of the content code so if the
quality of the content is good you're
probably going to get subscribers and so
if you're not getting subscribers you
want to take away that learning okay you
want to be able to understand what
people like and what they don't like and
that's the whole point of YouTube
analytics YouTube analytics allows us to
really adjust and hone in on you know
what people are liking and what they
don't like so that way you can move your
future videos in that direction so let's
go back to the creator studio
and let's look at some of the other
features available here so we actually
go from analytics to comments okay so we
can look at all the comments so right
now there's no comments available for
the video I just uploaded but if there
were I'd be able to see what those are
and I can you know report any spam or
actually review and respond to those
comments so when you actually do get
comments you'll be able to see them here
again helpful review again anything that
spam is going to show up a spam and so
you can go ahead and remove it or you
can approve it again and you can flag it
as spam so you have an option here to
let YouTube know hey this is spam we
don't want this type of comment in the
future again you can hold any comments
for you know responding later so if I
click on it again I can approve it and
then I can go back to public and I can
look at any comments that have been made
public and from there I can go ahead and
react to those comments and so I can go
ahead and reply give it a thumbs up give
a thumbs down like it and you can go
ahead and remove it or hide from the
channel ok you can always approve
comments from a specific user who always
responds or comments ok or you can add
the abbé SiC Euler user as a comment
moderator so you have a lot of options
available to you under comments and
comments are they really they're part of
the YouTube ecosystem so it's important
that if somebody's watching your video
just as you are now you comment so
there's anything that I'm missing here
then go ahead and comment right below
this video right on the channel and
comments are important because it allows
you know people to engage and interacts
with the person who created the video
and comments are always you know always
welcome whether they positive or not so
positive comments do add a lot to the
video itself it lets people express
their opinions lets people provide
feedback on the video and it allows the
you know the owner of the video to go
ahead and learn what people would think
about the video
and of course YouTube allows that person
to respond accordingly so that's an
important feature for both the viewer
and the publisher of the video okay so
let's look at some other features here
in the Creator studio so if I click on
transcriptions okay so I can transcribe
so I can choose here I can add a
language for example just by clicking on
add a language and so what YouTube's
going to do is add that particular
language to my channel and that's what
that language will be available for
people who are speaking that language
and then I have some other features
available here as well so if I go here I
got translation and transcription so if
I click on that again this is a little
bit different than adding a language as
a setting so now if I really want to go
ahead and select a different language
for my video I have a hundred 90 other
languages if I just choose Spanish
choose Spanish here
so what YouTube can do is make sure this
video is available in Spanish so if I go
back to my translation I can add the
language Spanish and then if I look on a
particular video then I can go ahead and
you know switch the language from
English to Spanish here I can go ahead
and edit the video any particular part
of the video I can go ahead and go ahead
and add subtitles and make this more
Spanish friendly so to speak so you have
this option available to you again this
is under other features translation and
transcription again transcriptions here
allow you to make your videos available
in that language if I go to translation
and transcription I actually have the
opportunity to add subtitles to parts of
my video in that particular language
then when I'm done I can go ahead and
submit my contribution so let's take a
look at some other features available to
us under other features so if I want to
go ahead and manage my different
playlists I can go ahead and select
playlists and YouTube's gonna open up a
new window and here I can see my one
video
that he uploaded earlier is in this
playlist here so I have the opportunity
to go ahead and edit that one video okay
I can go ahead and move it to a
different playlist go ahead and make
some other changes okay so I can go to
playlist settings and I can go ahead and
go ahead and order the types of videos
that are in that playlist in terms of
when they were added the most popular
when they were published so I have some
options available to me for the playlist
this particular playlist that I created
however if I go back I can go ahead and
go and add more playlists if I wanted to
so here I can go ahead and just say test
tagging again just make this private to
me or make it public and I just created
a new playlist so now I can add videos
to the playlist or go ahead and make
some setting changes to that playlist so
that's what playlists are it's a chance
for you to organize all your videos into
different playlists now some other
features available to us live stream so
if we click on live stream YouTube's
gonna open up a new window and now we
can livestream our video so live
streaming basically means that we're
gonna be able to record right here and
now okay so this is an opportunity for
you to really put yourself out there so
if you want to promote it ahead of time
that's probably wise so you can get
people to you know go ahead and watch
and take part in the live stream that
you have available to you so really live
streaming is just an easy way to reach
your audience in real time it could be
if you're streaming a video game or
hosting a live Q&A or teaching a class
basically whatever the reason is it
allows you to really get yourself out
there in front of your audience and so
the whole pre-record City is you want to
go ahead and promote the live stream
ahead of time so that people can take
part in the live stream so that's what
live streaming is so if I click on
status and features YouTube's gonna open
up a new window that shows me my status
and all the different features available
to me
in YouTube
Oh see my copyright status okay and good
standing okay so I don't have any
negative basically negative copyright
strikes against me so I'm in good
standing there so you want to follow
copyright rules in other words you know
don't grab something in your video
that's already copyrighted
okay so YouTube does look for that here
you can see we have all these different
features available to us from live
streaming we can enable it you know we
can enable longer videos okay so we have
all these different options available to
us you know custom thumbnails
annotations okay super chats so we have
all these options and some of them
require you know some account
verification some of them have
prerequisites for uploading more videos
in order to be eligible but if you want
to take a look at all the features that
are available just click on status and
features and YouTube will explain to you
what you're eligible for and what you're
not eligible for so remember if you want
to get to the creator studio you can
always just click on your icon in the
upper right when you click on the icon
you're gonna see YouTube studio beta
just click on that and when you click on
that that's where you're gonna get your
dashboard that's gonna be where you're
going to be able to edit your videos
look at analytics and insights respond
to comments add some transcriptions and
take advantage of other features so
that's the creator studio so again once
you get going with your YouTube channel
you upload the video and you adjust all
your settings I recommend you look at
the video how to increase YouTube
subscribers because it really does
complement this video on how to set up a
YouTube channel so take a look at the
video we get into really deep details
about how to increase your subscribers
because once you get the videos on your
channel you're gonna want to know all
the best practices in order to get
people to watch your video so I want to
thank you for your time if you have any
comments if you feel I missed anything
please feel free to add them to the
comments section under this video thank
you again and for more information
please visit simply learn com
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here